vamos a comenzar con una moneda justa
moneda justa y recuerden una moneda
justa es simplemente una que es
igualmente probable que caiga alguien la
que caiga sol y bien lo que voy a hacer
con esta moneda justa es echarme cuatro
ovalados así que voy a echar
cuatro volados
volados bien y lo primero que me quiero
preguntar es cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener exactamente exactamente
águila
aquí las recuerden yo digo allí leí sólo
ustedes pueden decir cara o cruz o lo
que ustedes quieran así que bien cuánto
es esta probabilidad
pues bien primero antes que nada vamos a
contar cuántos eventos podríamos
hacernos digamos que este es mi primer
volado segundo volado tercer volado y
cuarto volado y para el primer volado me
puede salir allí las olas así que hay
dos posibilidades para el segundo volado
también me puede salir águila o sol así
que hay otras dos posibilidades para el
tercer volado también hay dos
posibilidades de nuevo sólo puede ser
águila o sol y para el cuarto volado
también hay dos posibilidades varias
sorpresas también sólo puede salir
águila o sol entonces hay en total 16
modos posibles dos por dos es cuatro por
2 es 8 que por 12 16 16 modos posibles
de obtener una secuencia de volados es
decir hay 16 posibilidades o posibles
resultados 16 posibilidades
así que bien entonces si yo considero un
evento en particular por ejemplo me
pregunto por la probabilidad de no sé
obtener un águila luego un sol luego un
águila y luego otro sol entonces en este
orden en el primer volado segundo volado
tercer volado y cuarto volado entonces
este solo es uno de estos dieciséis
posibles eventos es uno de los
resultados que me podría pasar así que
la probabilidad de obtener esto sería 1
entre 16 muy bien entonces regresando al
problema la probabilidad de obtener
exactamente un águila es lo mismo que
la probabilidad de obtener el águila en
el primer volado que sería águila y como
ya obtuve el águila y sólo quiero
exactamente un águila todos los demás
tendrían que ser sol así que águila sol
sol sol más la probabilidad de obtener
el águila en el segundo volado que sería
sol luego águila y luego sol y luego sol
más la probabilidad de obtener un águila
en el tercer volado sol sol águila sol
más la probabilidad de obtenerla en el
último volado sol sólo el sol águila
casi se me acaba el espacio pero
afortunadamente si cupo algo que es
importante señalar es que la razón por
la cual puedo afirmar que esta
probabilidad es igual a la suma de estas
probabilidades es que si me sale
exactamente un águila entonces estoy en
este caso o en este caso o en este caso
o en este caso y si estoy en cualquiera
de estos casos no puede estar en los
demás es decir si me ha salido un águila
en el primer volado ya no me pueda
volver a salir otra águila entonces este
caso excluye a todos estos pues estos
tienen un águila en el segundo tercero y
cuarto
y si me sale un águila en el segundo
volado entonces excluya este y excluya
este ya este y así sucesivamente por esa
razón estas probabilidades se pueden
sumar de ese modo muy bien entonces como
decía cada uno de estos es un
dieciseisavo tiene probabilidad de un
dieciseisavo puesto que sólo representan
una posibilidad en específico de entre
las 16 posibilidades que hay así que
esto sería igual
1 entre 16 y ak + 1 entre 16 y ak + 1
entre 16 ya que más 1 entre 16 de aquí y
cuánto es eso sería 4 dieciseisavos
o lo que es lo mismo un cuarto la
probabilidad de obtener exactamente un
águila en cuatro volados con una moneda
justa es igual a un cuarto
ahora qué pasa si me pregunto por la
probabilidad de obtener exactamente
exactamente
dos águilas entonces la situación ya se
complica bastante y no es lo más
conveniente tratar de usar un método así
de cualquier modo yo sé que hay 16
posibilidades 16 resultados del
experimento de echar cuatro volados así
que aquí yo ya tenía hecho una tabla
déjenme la parezco bien ahí está mi
tabla con todos los resultados posibles
tras echarme cuatro volados y entonces
tengo que contar cuáles tienen
exactamente dos águilas veamos este de
aquí
este trabajo y este también
en esta columna no hay ninguno en esta
columna está este
también este
y también este y en esta columna no hay
ninguno así que 1 2 3 4 5 6 eventos de
entre 16 posibles o si simplificó la
fracción simplemente sería tres octavos
ahora este método se volvería
excesivamente complicado si en vez de
echar me cuatro volados me echaran no sé
diez o veinte volados así que sería
bueno pensar en otro enfoque otra razón
por la cual no es conveniente usar este
enfoque es porque si la moneda no fuera
justa si hubiera una pequeña diferencia
entre la probabilidad de que caiga
águila o caiga sol entonces esta tabla
no nos serviría de nada bien pues
entonces el modo en el que voy a pensar
en este problema va a ser el siguiente
quiero averiguar cuál es la probabilidad
de sacar exactamente dos águilas en
cuatro volados así que vamos a suponer
que aquí tengo mis cuatro volados primer
volado segundo volado tercer volado y
cuarto volado así que estos son los
volados
esto de aquí abajo
vamos a suponer que tengo dos águilas
digamos águila
y águila ve lo único que quiero decir
con esto no es que sean dos águilas
distintas o que cambia la moneda sino
simplemente que tengo que tener dos
águilas en los cuatro volados así que
bien para el águila
tengo la posibilidad de que me salga en
cuantos lugares pues me puede salir en
el primer volado en el segundo volado en
el tercer volado o en el cuarto volado
así que tengo cuatro lugares en los que
podría aparecer cuatro lugares cuatro
lugares
y qué hay del águila ve pues digamos que
el águila me apareció en el tercer
volado que apareció el águila entonces
el águila ya no puede aparecer aquí
tiene que aparecer en uno de estos tres
así que el águila ve solo tendría
tres lugares posibles
lugares
esto es para el águila ve y entonces
bien digamos podría aparecer aquí o acá
waka de cuántas formas podría obtener
dos águilas pues tengo cuatro lugares
para la primera y tres lugares para la
segunda entonces tengo doce resultados
pero hay que tener cuidado con algo y
esto es algo bastante importante
nosotros estamos acomodando dos águilas
entonces digamos que el águila me
aparece en el primer volado y el águila
bm aparece en el segundo volado y luego
me aparece un sol aquí y un sol acá pero
esto es lo mismo que el águila bm
aparezca en el primer volado y el águila
ame aparezca en el segundo volado y dos
soles estas dos cosas son iguales porque
en realidad las dos águilas son águila
ok el a y el b simplemente están para
recordarnos que necesito exactamente dos
águilas pero estas dos cosas son iguales
las dos son un una serie de volados
águila águila sol sol aguilar aguilar
sol sol entonces estos dos resultados
son 50 dobles y tomar a estas dos cosas
como distintas como para nosotros deben
ser iguales estas dos cosas estos dos
resultados de los volados entonces
necesito dividir entre 2
/
2 y esto es por culpa de los repetidos
por
repetidos
esencialmente lo que estoy diciendo es
que si necesitara por ejemplo sacar tres
águilas entonces varios casos serían
iguales cada vez que reacomodo esas tres
águilas obtendría un caso igual entonces
tendría que dividir no entre dos sino
entre el modo en el que puedo
intercambiar tres cosas del lugar así
que bien este 12 entre 2
me cambio de color
12 entre 2 sería igual a 6 así que hay 6
resultados
distintos
distintos esa es la diferencia estos
eran resultados genéricos pero no
necesariamente eran resultados distintos
como vimos aquí estos seis resultados si
son distintos así que de nuevo la
probabilidad de exactamente exactamente
dos águilas dos águilas va a ser igual a
pues tengo seis resultados distintos
entre 16 resultados posibles
16 resultados posibles tengo 2 aquí 2
aquí 2 aquí 2 aquí 2 por 2 x 2 x 2 es 16
así que de nuevo obtengo la respuesta de
tres octavos
o de hecho otro modo en el que podrían
pensar en esto y quizás sea también
conveniente que lo analicen
es decir pues tengo seis formas de
obtener dos águilas exactamente dos
águilas y cada una de ellas tiene un
dieciseisavo de probabilidad así que de
nuevo llegarían al mismo resultado de
tres octavos